una consulta revocatoria contra sí mismo
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador quiere saber si los
ciudadanos rechazan su gobierno o si le
permiten agotar su mandato hasta 2024 se
reafirma el criterio de que el pueblo es
el soberano
el que manda
el referendo solo es vinculante si la
participación llega al 40 por ciento
algo que se ve lejano sin embargo lópez
obrador tiene alrededor de un 60% de
popularidad y el 74% de los mexicanos
está de acuerdo con su continuidad por
lo que la consulta ha sido vista por la
oposición como una forma de
autopropaganda en este momento quien lo
está organizando es desde la propia
autoridad la propia autoridad se perdió
su propia confianza a sí mismo no verdad
no me parece que sea así se ya darse un
balazo en el pie el rival en los
discursos del presidente ha sido el
instituto nacional electoral este quería
retrasar la consulta por falta de
presupuesto y aunque la corte ratificó
la votación el ine sólo podrá desplegar
cerca de una tercera parte de las
casillas electorales respecto a los
últimos comicios parlamentarios además
de otras preguntas informales la del 3
de abril será la segunda consulta bajo
el amparo legal después de la del 1 de
agosto de 2021 cuando se preguntó por
investigar a ex presidentes mexicanos en
esa ocasión sólo votó un 8% la cifra a
batir